foreign
hey welcome to the show David
hi guys um you know I through the spirit
is actually gentleness so I kind of
appreciate that dude I'm so glad that
you are the call we picked up for this
guy did you hear that John he
appreciates it I said I told you I love
it he appreciates it we talk a lot about
a lot of stressful stuff on the show
John a little gentleness doesn't hurt
anymore I love it all right David how
can we help
um so I was in a relationship I was in a
marriage for 10 years and then my wife
left and it's kind of crazy am I in my
grief I rushed into another relationship
um
my new girlfriend is pregnant
um and we're trying to figure out the
best way to merge families now
um I was on my way to getting out that
um
um I was paying off and I was doing a
lot of things now but now
um with the
choice of
um joining the families and everything
that's going on I just want to know
what's best to prepare
um
because she lives in York and I actually
live here in Denver Colorado so um I was
like okay what do you all think are
y'all gonna get married or are you like
no not that but we're gonna
um no I do want to like okay hold on
real quick David David you're using a
lot of cryptic language and kind of
bouncing around okay
like everybody's grown up here just like
shoot it straight like you live in this
town you live in this town your
girlfriend's pregnant and now y'all are
thinking about what what comes next
um yeah we're gonna merge our family
what does that mean what does that mean
that you merge companies what are you
doing with your families y'all getting
married
yeah we want to get married okay and um
you know be uh be a family just one
family okay all right
so is she coming to Denver are you going
to go to New York
um I really want her to come to Denver
um
my you know my daughter I have a
daughter too so she's here and um
but she has her her doubts
um
she lives uh she she wants me to come to
New York the cost of living is lower in
New York
um but I find that
um even though the cost of living is
higher here in Colorado
they pay more you know to compensate for
the inflation so
um I'm the only one working she does not
work
um she does have a savings saved up and
I'm actually in debt trying to get out
um
everything okay back there
David
okay uh are you there
yeah I'm here I apologize about that
yeah you're good you're good no worries
no worries okay
so which so what what do you need help
from us you're calling the Ramsey show
what do you are you are you what do you
need
so I just want to best
um I wanted some maybe some insight on
on how to best prepare
um for foreign
y'all aren't even close to that
you're not even near that right now
you
she hasn't y'all haven't even agreed to
be in the same Community together in the
same state together on the same Hemet
side of the of the country together
okay
how do you combine families that I mean
at least we've got to get in the same
zip code
and so if I'm you I'm getting on a plane
and I'm gonna go fly down and sit in a
room and have a very grown-up adult
conversation with somebody that I I just
created a life with
and we're going to talk about what's
next
we're not going to talk about savings
accounts yet we're not going to talk
we're going to talk about what's next
who's gonna who's gonna change their
life
everybody's life's different now
everybody's life's different
is she gonna move to Colorado with you I
don't care about the cost of living and
how much inflation is she gonna move
with you so that you can be by your
daughter because your daughter's not
going to leave this to Colorado
um or are you going to pack up and leave
your current daughter to go be with your
new child
right so you see what I'm saying like we
have to have some very basic nuts and
bolts grown-up conversations
and then we're going to get into she I I
I've heard nothing that she's even
remotely ready to marry you or merge
families with you
um well she is she is and I'm sorry I
left that out okay yeah mainly she she
is and she um the the plan is to to live
here
um I just have some doubts because the
cost of living is cheaper over there but
I believe you know in terms of resources
that God will provide whatever but
um the plan is to move her down here
um David is she going to be leaving kids
there or will she she's not she will not
be leaving kids
um they're gonna come with her their
kids are not not involved okay how many
kids does she have I'm just curious she
has she has currently she has three and
then we're gonna have a four okay
so then there'll be five of us
um yes and so since you have a daughter
there
um
I
I could care less what inflation is I'm
gonna live in the same as close to my
daughter as I possibly can I have a
six-year-old there is no amount of
inflation that's going to take me away
from my daughter okay so let's consider
that problem solved geographically okay
and now it's about you figuring out what
kind of money is it going to take for
you to earn to take care of this family
when it comes to the relationship side
you and your girlfriend who's soon to be
your new wife are going to have to
create something entirely new
you're not taking you're not blending
this family with this one y'all are
making something totally new there's
going to be pieces of those other
families that go with you those three
kids dads tell us a a vote in their life
more than likely uh your ex-wife or the
mother of your other child has a voice
into your life so there's gonna be other
people speaking into your new world but
y'all are creating something totally new
and so look at it as an opportunity to
completely clear the deck and build
something beautiful and new okay the
more you try to
well this is the in this and bring
baggage from it the more you're gonna
you're gonna I'm trying to think of the
right way to say this no you well you've
said it before to me in a kind of a
different way of like after 9 11 when
the towers they didn't take the same
metal and tried to rebuild the same town
that's right they they got rid of
everything and bought something and
built something new so you're you're
building a whole new and that has to be
your mindset which I think is we're
doing something totally new yeah
absolutely absolutely thanks for the
call David good luck with everything